ah Mars the red planet and our potential
new
home well Mars isn't as hospitable as it
sounds it's really
inhospitable it might be a balmy 20° C
during the day but at night the
temperatures can drop to
-13°
C okay if you don't know what- 1553 cus
is it's intensely cold it's like- 243° F
it's the type of temperature that will
give you frostbite in seconds in minutes
you'll die from hypothermia seriously
guys learn the metric system also we do
the conversion for you in the closed
captions and if you think Uranus smells
bad well that's because you haven't been
to Mars yet yeah the red planet smells
like rust and gunpowder but when wear my
helmet all I smell is me and I smell
pretty good most of the time well you
wouldn't be able to breathe on Mars
anyway the planet barely has any
atmosphere most of it is carbon dioxide
with only Trace Amounts of oxygen
luckily this time we aren't sending you
to Mars we've decided to sacrifice Chase
for this Mission what did you mean by
sacrifice I mean send we've sent Chase
up to set up a base on s and report
[Music]
back hey he made it welcome to the red
planet kind of nothing here huh I
thought there'd be more stuff you know
Rico any
ideas I detect no breathable air high
levels of radiation exposure low
pressure and frequent dust storms if you
want to survive on Mars you must build a
habitat great idea how long will that
take with the materials you transported
aboard the Starship I calculate it will
take about 3 months to assemble a simple
base that's not so bad I better get
moving now building a habitat on Mars
wouldn't be so simple it's got to be air
tight and insulated to protect Chase
from radiation and Martian dust storms
it also needs to have a sustainable life
support system to manage air water and
waste and of course Chase will need to
get power from solar
panels you don't want to know where I
get my drinkable water from but I'll
tell you anyways I could extract water
from the Martian soil or atmosphere but
it's so much work instead I recycle
water from things like sweat and
pee I just try not to think about
it the sensors are picking up a micro
meteorite headed straight for the base
potential Hazard detected don't sweat it
Rico we got enough water base is fine
I've built it
myself here let me give you a tour of my
crib Welcome to the the fanciest pad on
the planet over here is where I sleep
and over here is where I eat and over
there is a
window and this is my luxury first a
corner in case I get hit by like a dust
storm those babies travel at like 100
kmh they could easily slice through my
space suit oh you got to see my Michelin
star Greenhouse it's five stars because
it's rated out of this world
it's my favorite place in the base only
thing is I had to build it unattached to
my main living quarters because Rico
forgot to include a tunnel in the first
base plan so now every time I got to go
check on my plants I have to go outside
it's
exhausting that's why I don't bother to
take off my helmet when I pop into my
habitat I'm all about
efficiency plus it's a lot to animate
actually check out these potatoes they
look pretty good take that Matt Damon
micro meteorite is approaching the base
I calculate the chance of it striking
the habitat as
8742 Rico silencio por I'm recording a
YouTube video my friend come on and what
I tell you round the
numbers okay where was I oh yeah
potatoes it takes a lot of work to grow
anything on Mars taters aren't my first
choice I'd grow Burgers if I could but
we work with what we
got I keep my Greenhouse nice and
pressurized and at a comfy temperature
of 16° C and for those of you who hated
the Recycled pea stuff you're going to
love this next part because as a
fertilizer for the Martian soil I use a
super special ingredient my poo not cuz
I'm a sicko but because Martian soil is
literally garbage figuratively speaking
it smells pretty bad in here but at
least it doesn't smell as bad as
[Music]
Uranus danger micrometeoroid has
breached the habitat you must go there
and
what ah damnn meteoroid sorry guys I I
got to go check this
[Music]
out your helmet has sustained minor
damage this is my favorite helmet Rico
do I have a spare somewhere you have an
extra helmet but I have bad news uhhuh
what what now the extra helmet is back
at the habitat of course of course it
is are you kidding me 3 months on Mars
and I just finally start getting this
thing working and Mars has to ruin
everything well at least I have tape
around here somewhere be back in a
minute here this should work Rico how's
that storm looking not good a dust storm
of this type it can last for days oh
great that leaves me no choice if I
don't make it back in time I'll lose
everything and die and I can't die now I
just finished building this sweet sweet
bachelor pad it's only a 5-second walk
for you to reach your living quarters
okay come on it's only 5 Seconds you can
do this chase you can do this get your
head in the game
boy oh helmet is useless I'll go without
it 5 Seconds to get back home I can
handle a little bit of frostbite I
highly advise you don't do this okay
well if I don't make it I'll see you
guys on my next adventure chase
out looks like the atmospheric pressure
killed him before the frostbite could
didn't I say going out there without a
helmet was a bad idea yeah don't try
this on your own and don't worry Chase
will be fine it's kind of a thing he
dies a lot but he always returns for
another adventure where should he go
next how about the stinkiest planet in
the solar
system well that's a story for enough
what
[Music]
if